For DC Comics fans, hopes have been growing
that Robin — Batman's legendary partner
in crime fighting — might get his own solo
movie someday.
After all, Warner Bros. is hard at work adapting
tons of DC Comics characters for appearances
in its shared cinematic universe.
If they're gonna give Aquaman his own movie,
no character's really out of the question
at this point.
And Robin's actually one of the most popular
and visible DC Comics characters ever!
It's tough to go very far without seeing our
favorite spandex sidekick on TV, whether it's
Teen Titans Go, Young Justice or in DC's animated
movies like Batman vs. Robin, and Justice
League vs. Teen Titans — or even as one
of the featured characters in 2017's Lego
Batman Movie.
"Riiiip!
That's better!"
He's even been named the second best sidekick
ever — right behind Ed McMahon!
"What an exciting idea!"
(audience laughs)
But just don't get too excited.
While Robin-related miracles can happen — Batman
did eventually let him wear pants — the
truth is that DC has probably already killed
the chance of a Robin movie.
And it didn't even require a crowbar!
He's already dead
Perhaps the most direct reason DC isn't going
to make a Robin movie is that, well...the
character's already been killed.
Robin's DC movie-verse death was first hinted
at in Batman v Superman, and then mentioned
outright in Suicide Squad.
Now, Batman goes through Robins like tissues,
so it's entirely possible that Warner Bros.
could pick up from one of the nearly half-dozen
other characters who've been the Boy — or
Girl — Wonder.
But that inflicts its own set of headaches...
Which Robin to choose?
While Batman has pretty much always been Bruce
Wayne — with only a few brief exceptions
— being Robin is basically the equivalent
of a superhero internship.
There was Dick Grayson, Jason Todd, Tim Drake,
Stephanie Brown, and Damian Wayne, who's actually
Bruce Wayne's murder-happy son.
Each choice would bring a certain amount of
baggage and convoluted backstory.
And no matter the choice, it'll probably annoy
some segment of comic book readers whose favorite
Robin wasn't picked.
Too much backstory
But let's pretend that Warner Bros. decides
that movie Batman does need a movie Robin.
The fact that Robin's already been killed
before the events of DC's new movies complicates
things even further.
Is the dead Robin Jason Todd, mirroring his
comic book death at the Joker's hands?
Was it Dick, the first Robin — or has he
already graduated to solo hero status as Nightwing?
What's the best way to introduce a living
version of Robin into DC's movies without
first delving into the twists and turns of
continuity?
Bringing in a new Robin would be complicated
enough in a Batman movie.
Don't hold your breath on a solo outing.
Boy, wonder how the fans really feel...
Perhaps the most direct and blunt reason that
there won't be a Robin movie is that, well,
plenty of people may not actually want it
after all.
And there's proof.
When people talk about how Jason Todd was
killed by the Joker, that's only half true.
In fact, the Joker had some accomplices — 5,343
comic book fans, to be exact.
In 1988, DC Comics put Jason into mortal jeopardy
at the end of an issue, then included a 1-900
number — y'know, the kind that costs money
to call — to decide his fate.
Even though only 72 more fans voted to kill
him off than those who called to keep him
alive, the fact that there wasn't an overwhelming
response for him to live kind of says something
about how much fans seemed to actually care
about Robin in general.
And that's not all.
Think about the fact that there have been
eight live action films starring Batman since
1989, and only two of them — Batman Forever
and Batman and Robin, widely known as the
crappiest two that fans hate the most — featured
the Boy Wonder.
Christopher Nolan's Batman trilogy performed
just fine without the added benefit of Robin.
And, no, shoehorning a Robin reference into
the end of Dark Knight Rises doesn't count.
"You should use your full name, I like that
name...Robin."
UGHHHHH.
Teamwork
Finally, and most importantly, the idea of
a Robin solo movie is pretty much impossible
when you think about it.
Since it's pretty much baked into his character
from the start, Robin just works better as
part of a team, whether it be in the Dynamic
Duo, or in a larger group like the Teen Titans.
Sidekicks are usually just reflections of
the primary hero — so what would a Robin
movie be without Batman?
Robin's first solo comic series in the '90s
shows Batman sending Tim Drake off to France
to learn kung fu — because everyone knows
the best ninjas come from Paris.
Robin's next solo series left him in Gotham
City to fight the Joker alone — while Batman
took off to Rio de Janeiro.
Would a Robin solo movie somehow contrive
to get Batman out of the picture in the same
way?
Just picture it.
"Uh, hi Commissioner, it's me, Robin.
Sorry, Batman's on vacation this week, so
he can't solve the horrible serial murderers
plaguing the city.
Umm, but hey at least he'll get a good tan."
"What?!
Surely you must be jesting!"
"No, I'm not jesting, sorry.
But, like, I'll totally do the voice if you
think that'll help.
*Ahem*: I am the night!
I am Batmaaaan!"
"Ohhh...catastrophic!"
At this rate, it'd be surprising if Robin
ever shows up in the DC Extended Universe
at all, let alone in a starring role in his
own superhero flick.
Then again, someone thought it was a good
idea to make a movie about Superman knock-off
Steel, starring a rapping basketball player:
"It's hammer time!"
"Aahh!!"
So, really, anything's possible.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube Channel.
Plus, check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too!